if you consider a cell as a factory then
lysosome inside the cell is nothing but
a shredding machine or recycling center
so in a straighting machine you can put
all the things that you don't want and
it shred it and recycle it
so the lysosome is very similar it has
battery of enzymes specially the
hydrolysis which can break down variety
of product and basically recycle them
but apart from this recycling and
clearance function lysosome is also very
important for metabolic sensing nutrient
sensing and sometime it is important for
transcriptional regulation and it may be
it plasma membrane repair as well after
take care of research it has been now
cleared that lysosome is involved in
many different cellular processes
ranging from metabolic sensing apoptosis
cytotoxic killing cholesterol transport
detoxification and many others so
lysosome emerged out to be a super
important organelle inside the cell in
this whole video we'll be talking about
how lysosome is important its internal
composition and its cellular functions
so lysosome has acid hydrolysis it has
no more more than 60 different types of
hydrolysis and these acid hydrolases
are mainly protease DNA's RNAs which
does tons of function apart from the
internal composition the membrane of the
lysosome is decorated with several ion
transporters which continuously pumps in
and out several ions and other nutrients
and it has a important meaning to it in
a second we will know that so first of
all the damaged proteins and the
inefficient enzymes all are degraded in
the lysosome by the action of lysosomal
hydrolysis and also the damaged RNA or
DNA can be degraded in the lysosome by
lysosomal dinosaur
lysosome can first kill I mean fuse with
endocytic physical or famous on which
contains external pathogen and say of
bacteria or virus and from our end or
lysosome to degrade that or maybe
sometime it can fuse with autophagy
vesicle and it might break down or
recycle one entire organ like
mitochondria in this example so lysosome
is generally spherical in size and
nature but when it fuse with Amazon it
forms the secondary kind of lysosome
known as endo lysosome and it secretes
all of its hydrolase DNA's iron is
enzyme to recycle this senile organelle
let's say now the fun part is the
lysosome has an extremely acidic
environment and it turns out all the
hydrolysis DNA is iron is etc work at a
pH of 4.6 but how this acidic pH is
maintained so on the lights on the
lysosome you have several transporters
and ion channels as I have mentioned and
among them most important is the proton
pump so which is of e-type ATPase which
pumps in hydrogen ion inside and as a
result but pH of the lysosome is
strictly maintained to four point six to
five an inch apart from these p-type ATP
ASE's
there are calcium transporters now
calcium level change or local cytosolic
calcium level changer spiking calcium
level could be very important for
lysosome trafficking and localizing the
rise was on into the specific cellular
location apart from that there are
several other transporter which allow
the degraded amino acid sugar and lipid
to be released in the cytosol such that
it could be utilized
after recycling in the lysosome right
now life ISM can also work as a nutrient
sensor because the components of mTOR
see pathway is actually associated with
ribosome it turns out mTOR pathway can
actually sense the nutrient availability
or growth signal in environment let's
say there are a lot of truth signals in
the environment and now it is the
situation is like feasible for cell to
grow and divide so that message would be
conveyed inside the cell by these mTOR
pathway and that is how blacks who don't
work like a nutrient sensor right and
whenever there is ample amount of growth
signals or mitogenic signal by ant or
pathway it would signal to create more
protein and thereby help the cell to
grow in size and in terms of
functionality as well now let's just
take a look where the lysosomal enzymes
are manufactured it turns out lysosomal
enzymes are manufactured in the ER on
the ribosomes attached to the rough
endoplasmic reticulum definitely every
protein is synthesized there after its
production it is delivered to the Golgi
apparatus and in the Golgi apparatus
there are sorting happening so quality
apparatus is the warehouse of the cell
so it would sort several proteins and
sort specifically the lysosomal proteins
were delivery it to the lysosome and not
any other organelle but lysosome has a
safeguard mechanism let's say one of the
acid hydrolases are mistakenly delivered
to mitochondria but really it doesn't
matter for the cell or doesn't matter
for the mitochondria because that acid
hydrolysis would be kind of inactivated
because it needs a pH of that and let's
say during delivery there is a problem
with the delivery machinery and the and
then leaks out in the cytoplasm still
the enzyme will be inactive because the
pH of the cytoplasm is kind of neutral
Excel
but peas enzymes to work optimally at
four point six to five range so this is
a safeguard mechanism that the cell has
we would talk about how the transport of
lysosomal hydrologists take place in lot
more details in this video let's say
from the vesicles from the ER is fusing
into the six golgi where the sorting
would happen now in physiology several
manual residues are sequentially trimmed
by Golgi - it is one and bin the the
vesicles or the proteins associated with
that is also moving towards the Golgi
apparatus in medial Golgi apparatus
manual residues are even trimmed and new
n-acetylglucosamine residues are
sequentially added now remember this
particular modifications that is
happening on the tag is important
because this tag is the one which would
be important for delivery of the acid
hydrolysis to the lysosome now after
several round of modification the nfl's
glucosamine transfer is add in acetyl
glucosamine and then deliver it into the
trans-golgi in the trans ecology and
spew galactose and n-acetylmuramic acid
residues are sequentially added and the
main thing is there is a phosphate on
Sporus enzyme which transfers a
phosphate residue onto the mammals so it
is a mannose-6-phosphate
tag which is a lysosome specific
delivery tag now this delivery tag is so
important because phosphorylated mannose
6 residue can bind to
mannose-6-phosphate receptor on the
trans-golgi now this mannose 6-phosphate
receptor allow it to be packaged in form
of specific vesicles and that vesicle
goes and bind to I mean fuse to the
lysosome now inside the lysosome
there is acidic environment right
because the protons are pumped inside
the lysosome and the pH is 0.625 in that
situation the interaction between the
mannose phosphate receptor and the
man-whores phosphate tag is kind of
destabilized
so the enzyme which is the hydrolase is
kind of detached and skipped inside the
lysosome and the receptor is recycled
back and could be used for second round
of transportation now this mechanism of
tagging is so important because many of
the cases it has been seen there are
defects in the phosphor transferase
enzyme which gives this mannose
6-phosphate tag and in that situation
several products has been accumulating
in the GALT golgi and creating storage
lysosomal storage disorders that is why
lysosomal protein trafficking is very
important and normal life small
physiology is important for clearance of
the cellular junk or cellular waste
inside the cell so that concludes my
video on this topic I hope you enjoyed
this video if you liked this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you